What we want to do in this video
is figure out the mass
of calcium carbonate we need
to react completely with 25
milliliters of 0.75 molar
hydrochloric acid solution.
And we have the reaction here.
And just to remind ourselves
what we're talking about we
have this hydrochloric acid, and
it is dissolved in water.
It is an aqueous solution.
The solvent is water, and this
0.75 molar tells us the
molarity of that solution.
It tells us the concentration
or the moles of hydrochloric
acid per liter of our
entire solution.
And we need to figure out the
mass of this calcium carbonate
that we need to react
completely with the
hydrochloric acid solution.
This amount of it.
Now before we do any
stoichiometric problems, we
have to make sure that our
actual equation is balanced.
So let's do that first. So on
the left-hand side right here
we've got a calcium.
That's the only calcium.
And on the right-hand side
we only have 1 calcium.
So everything looks good from
the calcium point of view.
On the left-hand side we
have a carbon here.
I'll do it in pink.
We have 1 carbon here, and then
we have no carbons here.
And on the right-hand side
we only have 1 carbon.
Everything looks good so far.
On the left-hand side we
have 3 oxygens, no
oxygens over here.
And over here we have 1 oxygen
and then 2 more.
We have 3 on the right-hand
side.
Everything looks good so far.
On the left-hand side we have
1 hydrogen right there.
And then on the right-hand
side we have 2 hydrogens.
We have 2 hydrogens here.
So to balance it let me put 2--
let me put a 2 in front of
the hydrochloric acid, the
aqueous solution of
hydrochloric acid.
Now the hydrogens balance out,
and we haven't done the
chlorines yet, which is good,
because that would have messed
up everything if they were
already balanced.
But let's see.
Now we have 2 chlorines
on the left-hand side.
How many do we have on
the right-hand side?
We have 2.
So now this equation is balanced
after we threw that 2
coefficient on the hydrochloric
acid.
So now let's figure out what
mass of calcium carbonate do
we need to react completely
with this much of 25
milliliters of a 0.75 molar
hydrochloric acid solution.
Now the whole way to think about
it is I've given-- this
is how this problem is different
than everything else
we've seen so far is that I
haven't given you the mass of
hydrochloric acid.
I haven't told you the moles
of hydrochloric acid.
I've told you the amount
of solution containing
hydrochloric acid and
the concentration.
So what we're going to do is
take this information to
figure out the moles of
hydrochloric acid in this
reaction, how many moles do
we have in this solution.
And then for every 2 moles of
hydrochloric acid we're going
to need 1 mole of calcium
carbonate.
You're going to see that.
And then we just have to figure
out well, given that
we're going to need half as many
moles here as there are
here, how much mass is that.
So let's do that.
So we are starting off with the
25 milliliters of-- let me
write this-- 0.750 molar HCl
solution, and let's convert
this to moles of hydrochloric
acid.
So the first thing we need to
think about is that molarity
is always expressed in
moles per liter.
This is expressed in milliliters
right now.
So I want to get rid
of the milliliters.
I want it to be in liters.
So I want to multiply it by
liters-- I'll just write it as
a capital L-- as liters
per milliliter.
And we know we have 1 liter
per 1,000 milliliters, or
there's 1/1000 of a liter per
milliliters, however you want
to view it.
That's going to cancel
out that milliliters.
And then we want to convert--
we want to use this
concentration information to
figure out the actual number
of moles of hydrochloric acid
we're dealing with.
So to do that we're going to
multiply it times 0.750 moles
of hydrochloric acid per liter
of-- or I'll write this--
0.750 molar hydrochloric
acid solution.
So let me make sure
you understand
what I'm doing here.
I first want to get the 25
milliliters into liters, so
I'm going to essentially divide
by 1,000 and the units
will work out.
We have a milliliters in the
numerator, milliliters in the
denominator, we're left
with a liter on top.
And then I want to convert
from the solution to the
actual number of moles.
And if something is a-- I could
put a 0 right here--
0.75 molar, that means that
there is 0.75 moles of
hydrochloric acid per liter
of the solution.
This is just-- I'm just
saying you can
call that the solution.
And so this'll cancel out.
We have the liters canceling
out with the liters.
And then you can even say the
of 0.75 molar hydrochloric
acid solution cancels out with
the of .750 molar hydrochloric
acid solution.
And then you're left with--
let me stay in the same
color-- 25 times 1 times 0.750
divided by 1,000 moles of
hydrochloric acid.
And let's get our calculator
out to solve
for this right here.
So that is, let's see, 25 times
0.75 divided by 1,000 is
equal to 0.01875.
Let me write that down.
So this is equal to 0.018--
if I want to stick with
significant digits I really
don't have any more than three
significant digits here, so I
really shouldn't have any more
than three here.
So I could say 0.018-- instead
of 75 I'll just round it-- 8
moles of hydrochloric acid.
And now we know that for every
2 moles of hydrochloric acid
we need 1 mole of calcium
carbonate.
So we want to know the moles of
calcium carbonate required.
So let's do that.
So let's multiply this times--
we want this thing
to cancel out here.
We want that to cancel out.
So we want to know, so for every
mole of hydrochloric
acid, or for every 2 moles of
hydrochloric acid, we see that
there, for every 2 moles of
hydrochloric acid we need 1
mole-- I'll do it in that same
orange color-- we need 1 mole
of calcium carbonate
is required.
And so these moles of
hydrochloric acid is going to
cancel out with that moles
in the denominator.
And we're essentially just going
to take this number and
multiply it by 1 and divide
by 2, or just essentially
divide it by 2.
So let's do that.
I could just take the original
number right here, divided by
2-- I should only do it three
significant digits-- so it's
really-- well I'll just stay
with this-- so 0, 0, 9, 3, 8
just to round it.
So this is equal to, we're left
with 0.00938 moles of
calcium carbonate required.
And we're not done yet.
Remember, the question that we
asked is what's the mass of
calcium carbonate required.
So we need to figure out, we
need to essentially multiply
this times the molar mass.
So we want to convert this into
grams. Let's convert this
into grams. I'll switch colors
just arbitrarily.
And to put it into grams you
have to figure out the molar
mass of calcium carbonate.
And the molar mass of calcium--
you could look up
the atomic weight of calcium
on a periodic
table-- it is 40.
And then you're going to have a
carbon in there, that's 12,
we've seen that a lot.
Then you have an oxygen,
which is 16, but we
have three of them.
So 16 times 3 is 48, so it's
going to be 40 plus 12 plus
48, which is equal to 100.
So it has a molar mass of 100.
So times 100 grams of calcium
carbonate for every-- let me
just write that-- grams of
calcium carbonate for every
mole of calcium carbonate.
And we know we're doing the
right thing by multiplying by
100 because these units
cancel out.
Moles of calcium carbonate in
the numerator, moles of
calcium carbonate in
the denominator.
So those cancel out.
So we essentially just have to
multiply this thing times 100.
So let's do that.
So that thing times 100.
So times 100 is equal to--
and we had rounded
it-- so it's 0.938.
So let me write that.
0.938.
So it equals 0.938 grams
of calcium carbonate.